So what I show you is, is the opening,
and we typically use a disk or a square
that can it can, can also smooth
contours, but it'll typically break thin
connections eliminate small islands,
so small little spurious things.
Also sometimes eliminate
some sharp peaks.
The closing can smooth contours
where they, at the, concavities.
It'll fuse narrow breaks, so
things that were supposed to be
connected but had a little hole in them.
It'll, it'll do that.
And it can, you know,
sort of fill in these gulfs.
So often you'll do one followed
by the other, all right?
So here's an example.
This is the original image, okay?
And it's, it's a fake image obviously,
just to make the point.
So here's our original image.
And you'll notice it has,
you know, th, this cut out here,
th, these rough edges here, this kind of
noise here, these spurious things there.
And the opening, all right,
does exactly what you think.
It'll eat away this stuff, this stuff,
that stuff, and that stuff, all right?
And also these little ridges up here.
A closing, all right, well,
what that's going to do is that'll fill
in this hole, so that's gone there.
Fill in that whole thing, so that's gone
there, and fill in these things there.
Okay, remember neither opening nor
closing are going to grow or
shrink things right?
They're not erosions or dilations.
One is a dilation
followed by an erosion.
Which one is that?
That's a close and, the other one's
an erosion, followed by a dilation,
that's an open.
Well, when you do an opening
followed by a closing, okay, so you
take this and then you close that, you
get rid of this, you get rid of this,
you get rid of that, you get
the two underlying elements, okay?
So, the idea is that was what
you really wanted, all right?
And these kinds of operations
are what we use often.
So to show you a real life example of
that here's a fingerprint example.
Here's the original image.
You, here are the ridges
that you want to find.
There's a whole bunch of
spots you don't want to find.
There are some gaps that are not real,
right there.
And so what they do is they apply
an opening, followed by a closing.
And you get this really
nice fingerprint image.
Okay, so that's an example of,
of doing it for real.
Something I'm not going to talk about
now, there's something called a hit or
miss transform.
It's basically how to
find a particular shape.
By the way Lynn Shapiro,
I think it's in Shapiro and Stockman, or
another book that Lynn
was associated with ha,
in their textbook, they have a whole
bunch of stuff on morphology.
So if you need to know more of
the details you can go get that.